before we have a go at this particular
question right what we're going to have
a look at this morning
are just further applications on what
can we do
now that we have these things up our
sleeves vector equations of lines
can you help me remember why did we
introduce vector
equations of lines we're actually pretty
good at representing lines
or we were pretty good at representing
lines without vectors
why did we feel the compelling need to
say for example if i want some line uh
r can you help me remember i think we
start with an
a customarily right what's this thing
it has a name it's the position vector
it's like okay
first to get to represent this line get
onto the line get there somehow and then
what do we add
yeah we put in um some constant
coefficient
it's the parameter we can change it
right and we multiply by
a a well yeah another
another vector right uh and this is a
different vector it's not the position
vector we call it the
direction vector because it's like we
get onto the line and then you think
about well
now which way are you facing right and
you can have you know the opposite
version of b and you'll still be on the
line you can have any
multiple of b and you'll still be on the
line
um why did we introduce this like why
did we
abandon the idea of a cartesian equation
for a line in three dimensions yeah
so there's only one variable lambda
instead of three x y and zero
ah very good so we knew actually that
underneath this
there are the three um variables that we
need
for three dimensions but it's just kind
of a mess right we would uh in parallel
to this we would say something like
xyz which represents this
three-dimensional uh
vector here can be stated as well this
is
three-dimensional and then
this is three dimensional so
the whole idea of a vector equation of a
line is to say
well i just i'm a bit lazy i want to
concisely say in a single
equation uh what's going on with my line
rather than using an x and a y and a z
equation okay but as you're going to see
in these examples here
it is always important to have those
three parametric equations
sort of in the back of your mind as you
operate on these things
okay so what can we do with them have a
look at this particular question here
let's try and unpack
what it's doing and how we get there
find
the vector equation of a line through a
parallel with ob
and then they give you some a and some b
we'll have a look at those in a second
and then the secondary part of the
question which we won't worry about just
yet is the main point of what we're
doing this for
determine whether or not this other
point c is
on this line so this is the question
in two parts let's start with the first
one we need a vector
equation of a line and the first thing
i'd encourage you to do is to read that
question carefully
and note maybe you want to put let's
call this example one
maybe you want to put a little diagram
here for yourself
we've got three points that even before
we get to this last part of the question
um we've got three points we need to
worry about right
you've got the two ones that you're
given coordinates of so i'm just going
to call this a
and this b and then what's the third
point that's uh
mentioned oh the origin right so i've
got a
b with reference to o okay now
this is so important that i think it's
worth actually drawing we're going to
end up drawing two very simple diagrams
right
you're going to be asked very very
frequently for some a
and some b coordinates like so like we
did on tuesday
you're going to be asked very frequently
to find the vector equation of a b
right so i guess in this geometric
scheme we would
do it like this right here's a b it's
like is
is that is that what you're after
okay now i'm purposely asking you to
draw this and then
right beside it say no
because how do i know this is actually
not what's being asked because it says
yeah fantastic even the question itself
it never even says a b
right it starts to give this other
information about let's draw another a
and a b and an o just beside here
[Music]
i'm thinking back to in your ap threes
how often
one of you said to me i just didn't read
the question
i knew what to do and what i thought i
was supposed to do i did correctly it
was just
the wrong thing i think of like my
seven-year-old son who like
ducks and weaves on the soccer field and
it's like yes i scored
wrong goal okay so you need to know what
direction
you're heading in it happens
embarrassingly often so
we're looking for a line through a
through a right and then what's the
other information i need
parallel to ob so let's go ahead and put
ob on here
there's ob and i want something through
a that's
parallel to that so i guess i could well
let's try and eyeball this right
something like that okay you've got a
better perspective on the whiteboard
than i do so don't judge me please
um i can fix all this by saying let's
just mark these in
as parallel lines this is what i really
want
does this make sense okay now let me
just hit pause for a moment having given
you
this and then you can say yes
this is what i'm after take a moment and
see if you can work out
what the vector equation of the line
would be
remember we're looking for really two
things right we need a
position vector we need to get onto this
line
and then we need a direction vector to
say from that point
which way are you facing now i'll give
you a bit of a clue
it requires zero calculation
or arithmetic you can actually if you
look carefully at the information in the
question
you can just read it off anyone want to
give me a suggestion for a position
vector
uh andy you gave me a good thought
already did you
okay fantastic so i want to get on to
this line over here
i can pick any of these points but the
only point i am actually already handed
is a so therefore this is going to be my
little a is that okay get onto the line
capital is on there so
the particular vector in this case will
be actually what are our numbers
you can like i literally can't read them
off what do we got it's uh is it
negative 2
and 3. there you go there's my position
vector so i've got that noted down
now i need a direction vector now what
did you tell me last time about
like when you're trying to work out
you've got parallel lines what can you
say
about the direction vectors of parallel
lines
they can either be just flat equal to
each other or
like if for example what is it it's a
one zero one
that's this vector we want to be
parallel to right this is not the only
vector
that's one zero one's not the only
vector that's parallel to this you could
think of
infinitely many vectors that were
parallel right could someone just
give me an example just say one
negative 1 0 negative 1 if we were to
represent that here
that would look something like i guess
this do you agree
it's still going to be parallel because
it doesn't matter which of these
directions you're facing and you're fine
right
or maybe 2-0-2 i mean it's a bit
unnecessary but you get the idea
you have infinite choices here make
sense so therefore we can say
let's go ahead and represent it here
this can be our
b isn't it convenient it's almost by
design that our little a is going to be
a
sorry our big a is going to be a and our
big b is going to be b so
1 0 1. is that all right so as i
mentioned
no calculation necessary i can just
state that our vector equation of this
line
get onto the line here it is negative
two negative one
three and then tell me which way to face
lambda
one zero one okay you happy with that
now i remember we introduced this idea
or i reminded you of the idea
that lambda is our parameter as you
change
lambda you move along this line here
every point on this line can be
described by a single value of lambda
just like any point on the unit circle
can be described by some appropriate
choice of theta right you tell me the
theta i'll tell you where you are on the
unit circle
you tell me the lambda i'll tell you
where you are on this line
keep that in mind when you have a look
at the second part of the question right
we now have a vector equation
for the line great what we want to do is
determine
is this point c is it on that line
or not my clue for you is to think about
what lambda would get you to such point
on the line let me give you a couple
minutes to have a bit of a play
i'm just going to jot down now what this
point is because i'm about
to put a different question on the board
in case you get that one
lickety-split and you'll have some other
things to do see if you can have a go
importantly the working is what i'm
after even if you can say
yes it's on there or no it's not i
really want to know but
how did you prove that that's really
what i'm after okay
so there's the corner see give you a
couple minutes to play and i'll shut up
so you can actually concentrate
is c on the line
no it ain't right but how did we know
that's the important part right
now there's a few different ways to do
this and i'm mindful of time so i wonder
if
friend can you start us off just giving
like the skeleton you don't have to like
talk it through every line but
how did you even begin what was your
approach
with the equation of the line to
parametric
okay so we split this off into its three
different
bits okay so you've got an you've got an
x equals a y equals
and a z equals that's the first thing
you did yep and then keep going
uh once i got the parametric equations i
solved
um x equals zero to
be like the x component of c okay so
let's uh
let's just make sure we understand
what's going on here right varene has
said
okay i've got my three parametric
equations right and apparently
if i do go through c right
the x coordinate of c is zero so i
should be able to find remember this is
me mentioning this before
i should be able to find the appropriate
lambda that would get me to
to that point right um did anyone else
begin this same way
yeah i'm getting a few nods yeah okay
frankie keep going what did you do
you got some version of lambda yeah some
value for lambda sorry and then what
oh once i found the value for lambda i
just subbed it into my other parameter
equations to see if it matches with
c what was that value for lambda by the
way two two
so you solved this equation you had a
zero over here
some stuff here with lambda you tied it
all up you found this value
and then substitute it in now you got
what uh
negative one five negative one and then
five you've got x equals zero y equals
negative one z
equals five now this is a bit funny
isn't it because you're like
i was hoping to get four maybe and that
would have told me yes it's on the line
but i've got this other value so you try
and get the right lambda
and you get pretty close but you're like
oh i'm off right now this is one way to
say
okay i know something has gone wrong
you're correct uh in that this is not
this is one of the reasons why you can
say seasonal online
did anyone else have a different
approach what'd you do
interesting okay did you did you all
catch that this is actually really
important to understand because
just like i was emphasizing right stay
with bishop
just like i was emphasizing for
something as simple as tell me the
equation of the line there's an infinite
choice of
position vectors there's an infinite
choice of direction
vectors there's an infinite number of
ways to slice and dice and approach this
question
right let me see if i've got this right
terence when you
you tested out x equals 0 you've got a
lambda and then instead of taking lambda
you then said well i want to get
different i want to get negative one and
i want to get
four that's what i should get right
presumably based on what varendra said
you've got lambda equals two here as
well
but you got a different lambda
oh because of the because it's zero it's
like fat lot of use you were right so
you just
just kind of ignore that what lambda did
you get for zed
one so because you've got again
it's from a different perspective though
right you got this mismatch from what
you were expecting
right so this tells you something has
gone wrong
these are both fine i like both of them
let me give you a third
morgan do you want to give us another
one okay sure um
so because the equations are
the line equation this one here would
help us to find
so let's just presume that the equation
works first so on the left side we're
going to put in
vector c yep and then on the right hand
side we just bring the
line so we use the left deducted
right-hand side
to find out the values equal to lambda
oh yeah let's just put in everything
right
so you have this and then
um to find out the alignment we have to
use 1100
uh without the negative two negative one
and three oh just pause there pause
there
what what's morgan doing what's his goal
like is he's about to throw some
arithmetic at us
he's trying to solve for lambda at this
point right which in some way shape form
exactly what
friend did and what turin did but
getting at it from quite a different
angle
right to get lambda on its own we
clearly need to do some collection of
like terms here
right so you've subtracted have i got
that right you subtracted this vector
from both sides okay of course we've got
to watch out for these double negatives
so what did you get
and then you're gonna get two o and
three
add two and one sorry yeah and then
we're going to get that
but then we're going to find out that
because the electrolyte is never going
to be a scale effect
very good um it's almost like i planned
this is almost in fact i'll even prove
it to you
uh let me see here let me switch this
over for you
that's what i wanted okay
here's one i prepared earlier this is
more or less exactly what
morgan said have you been looking my
notes morgan when you have a look what
are we trying to do in all three of
these methods right one two
three in this case because c is not on
the line what we are searching for is
think back to our topic from last term
we're searching for a contradiction of
some kind right we've all assumed
something
that there should be some value of
lambda that works for all of them
right or if we take our point c it
should give us the same lambda all the
way through
or again to use the language actually i
think i might have written here right
uh did i yeah there it is right there
right we assume there exists some lambda
that should
satisfy this equation but having gotten
to this point as morgan helps us with
arithmetic just to simplify it down
it's quite obvious there isn't okay now
just as a uh
a post script to this question can
someone help me
to find some point d that is
on the line on the basis of what we have
just all worked
out
okay i can just say well i don't know we
got lambda equals two before and we we
gave it a good hot go in fact i think
maybe turn
that's kind of what yuso did no hold on
am i
no i'm getting i'm getting all my
methods confused um i can take some
given value of lambda and i can
substitute it into
my parametric equations um well actually
i think this is no it is yes i'm not
confused 0 negative 1
5 0 negative 1 5. that should be on the
line that's what we got by testing out
varen's method right at the beginning
right which should make sense because
we're just off by one are we so if we
just
go off a little bit and this isn't the
only way you could do it by the way
you could say go the other direction if
this was one zero one
you'd have a lambda of one and you'd be
on a different point on the line does
that make sense